die drei fragezeichen die meisten von
ihnen kennen sie bestimmt sind diese
drei detektive ich muss zugeben ich habe
als kleines mädchen lieber bibi und tina
gehört und meine freundin rock sie
musste mich immer überzeugen dass ich
auch mal die drei fragezeichen höre sie
aber in großer fan und einzig denn heute
im tagesspiegel den artikel gelesen habe
der schon ein jahr alt ist aber den ich
heute erst gelesen habt ihr wurde
zugespielt über twitter habe ich gedacht
das kann doch nicht deren ernst sein es
war meine freundin roxy die drei
fragezeichen gelebt hat die sollte das
eigentlich nicht mehr hören kind auf
jeden fall wenn es nach der redakteur
redakteurin nach vom tagesspiegel geht
denn die drei fragezeichen kids würden
männliche machtfantasien rüberbringen
also sie möchten nicht dass ihr sohn ihr
kleiner sohn weite die drei fragezeichen
kids hört denn das weltbild von ihm
würde problematisch geprägt werden sie
findet dass die welt der drei
fragezeichen aus einem sexistischen
frauenbild und einer dominierenden
männerwelt besteht als begründung führt
sie auf es bis zur folge 71er nur 130
von 872 rein weiblich gewesen wären und
die werden telefon da meerjungfrau und
tante mathilde kuchen backt gewesen ich
hab immer als kind bibi und tina gehört
und wenn jetzt die drei fragezeichen
sexistisch sein sollen und das
problematisch dann fordere ich für bibi
und tina eine männerquote weil es kann
ja auch eigentlich nicht sein dass immer
nur zwei mädchen die welt retten und
eine kann noch zaubern ich finde dass
absoluten schwachsinn las den kindern
die drei fragezeichen
janina dass diese debatte zeigt was
alles quer läuft oder verkehr läuft in
der in der debatte um zu ändern und um
mainstream also ohne zu platt zu werden
das ist völlig verquer was sie geäußert
wird warum weil jeder der die drei
fragezeichen ist wahr ist dass diese
drei bob justus und peter diese drei
jungs im grunde in einer eigenen welt
leben völlig entkoppelt auch von tante
mathilda und gibt es natürlich den
inspektor nach der dann rolle spielt und
den erzähler aber viel mehr auch nicht
die lösen die fälle völlig autark und
nehmen wahrscheinlich auch meistens
jugendliche männer daneben oder oder
jungen jungs damit in ihrer welt und
unter lösen diese fälle völlig entfernt
von allem anderen also dass hier ein
männliches bild vermittelt wird kann
männliche macht für ein männlich
machtfantasien und macht haben wir schon
gar nicht weil sie ihre weil sie sich ja
immer entgegenstemmen hin mächtigen oder
den den scheinbar cleveren und durch
ihren biss durch ihr geschickt durch
ihre jugend dann auch tatsächlich diese
verschafften zu lösen und insofern und
tante matilda ist eigentlich sehr
dominant ermahnt sie schimpft mit ihnen
vielleicht auch überkommene
vorstellungen aber ganz im gegenteil sie
ist ja nicht nur jemand der noch kuchen
backt sondern ist eine der zentralen
figuren da drin also ich kann das gar
nicht nachvollziehen und hanni und nanni
ja klar da müsste dann oder alle anderen
frauen basierten oder mädchen basierten
filme geschichten da jetzt künstlich
noch männer einzufügen oder jungs
einzufügen finde ich auch verkehr lasst
doch bestimmten geschlechtern irischen
spaß sich zu verlieren in bestimmten
rollen sind ja auch von den drei
fragezeichen ganz viele frauen fans also
es ist ja gar nicht nur für jungs als
ich habe jetzt meine freundin roxy als
praktisches beispiel weil ich immer bei
den drei fragezeichen ein wie denkt man
verbindet ja immer sachen aus der
kindheit mit sachen und die spielen ja
ganze stadien sind ja auch tourneen von
denen unter sitzen frauen und männern
ist einfach ein schönes hepting deswegen
aber die frage ist natürlich sehr schade
haben sie vielleicht auch die drei
fragezeichen weil politik verbindet man
immer mit männlichen machtfantasien er
hat erst recht bei ihnen dazu geführt
dass sie in die politik gegangen sind
ich habe das gelesen allmachtsfantasien
soll es für ganze generationen ausgelöst
haben also wir haben es gemeinsam
spielen und ich wir haben anscheinend
beide die drei fragezeichen
ich habe wirklich gelesen ich bin ja mal
der hat sie wahrscheinlich auch ich
hab's ja auch genießt sogar mal da
hingefahren und habe geguckt wo kann das
sein sie hat nämlich dahinter los
angeles auf dem weg nach malibu gibt es
gibt ja geschichten wo das hätte es gibt
den olfener nicht locken sie kommen ja
aus rocky beach und rocky beach gibt es
natürlich nicht aber es gibt eine eine
erklärung im netz wo ausgiebig sein
könnte da bin ich mal von barrieren
hingefallen habe genug gemacht natürlich
auch ins schrottplatz in der nähe also
ein paar häuser die aus werden schreibt
aber die drei habe ich leider nicht
gefroren so auf den spuren der drei
fragezeichen
aber ich einfach ein bisschen mehr
gelassenheit bei dem thema glaube ich
ist ist total wichtig weil ich glaube
nicht dass ganze generation jetzt
allmachtsfantasien haben nur weil sie
die drei fragezeichen gelesen hat egal
ob männlich oder weiblich und von daher
kann ich nur jedem empfehlen sie zu
lesen weil ich habe sie regelrecht
verschlungen ich kann mich noch gut
daran erinnern hat die bücher und auch
bei mir zuhause zu steht ja schon
auf ein drei fragezeichen gesetzt als
erhofft man ja mit meinen töchtern weiß
ich dass es drei ausrufezeichen gibt das
sind nämlich drei mädchen die
entsprechend auf verbrecherjagd gehen
also gibt es etwas das problem ist weil
es gibt für die mädels drei
ausrufezeichen für die jungs drei
fragezeichen und wäre dann mehr
allmachtsfantasien entwickelt mit man
dann ja sehen ja im geschlechterkampf
also ich sehe das problem nicht da
müsste man sich natürlich die drei
ausrufezeichen einmal anschauen das habe
ich nicht getan ist wusste ich auch bis
gerade mal anhören und sebastian drei
fragezeichen fan oder auch er tkkg
übrigens die werden tage spielen wir
auch aufgegriffen sie diesen auch nicht
mehr gut sein für das weltbild von
kindern ich hab das nicht gelesen oder
nicht gewürdigt pleiten hab ich gelesen
dass ja ja
ich wundere mich dass ich muss sagen
deswegen haben sie plötzlich angelegt
werden an solche sachen das ist ja alles
das sind ja irgendwie angehörige
irgendwelche wo ist da die ist von der
universität jetzt alles durchleuchten
nach irgendwelchen sehr seltsamen
kriterien ich habe mich auch sehr
gewundert als ich die kritiken zu wetten
dass jetzt gelesen hat zum beispiel wo
es plötzlich hieß das ist ja
rückwärtsgewandt das aus der zeit
gefallen der alte weiße mann thomas
gottschalk über sowohl wovon reden wird
der konzern das sind das hat das hat
menschen offensichtlich über 14
millionen menschen irgendwie also freude
gemacht diese sendung warum redet man
das jetzt schlecht und redet auch die
zuschauer schlecht auch das sind
irgendwelche anorak träger aus
abgeschlossenen geländes konnten ich
verstehe es nicht was hier sehr seltsame
kriterien angelegt werden plötzlich
lasst den leuten noch mal den spaß lasst
uns doch mal unser wetten dass lasst uns
in der ticker kg was was wollen die denn
von uns lasst uns unsere drei
fragezeichen ja